MARGALIT FOX: Thank you all
so much for coming.
I'm Margalit Fox, and I'm
particularly gratified to get
to talk to code people today
about what is essentially a
secret code from the
ancient past.
So here's how our time together
will be organized.
I'm going to read a brief
selection from my new book,
"The Riddle of the Labyrinth,"
and then I will talk about the
heuristics of exactly how one
goes about deciphering an
unknown script from
the ancient past.
After that, I will be delighted
to take questions.
And then we will have a small
stampede or a big stampede to
sign books.
So the opening of our book is
called "Buried Treasure," and
it opens at Knossos
on the island of
Crete in the year 1900.
"The tablet, when it emerged
from the ground, was in nearly
perfect condition.
A long, narrow rectangle of
earth and clay, it tapered
toward the ends, resembling
a palm leaf in shape.
One end was broken.
That was not surprising
after 3,000 years.
But the rest of the tablet was
intact, and on it, inscribed
numbers were plainly visible.
Alongside the numbers was a
series of bewildering symbols,
which looked like no
writing ever seen.
In the coming weeks, workmen
would lift from the earth
dozens more tablets, some
fractured beyond repair,
others completely undamaged.
All were incised with
the same curious
symbols, including these.
The tablets were what
Arthur Evans had
come to Crete to find.
It had taken him only a week to
locate the first one, but
his discovery would
forever change the
face of ancient history.
On March 23, 1900, Evans,
a few carefully chosen
assistants, and 30 local workmen
had broken ground at
Knossos in the wild countryside
of northern Crete
near present-day Heraklion.
He was rewarded almost
immediately.
Even before the first week was
out, his workmen's spades
turned up fragments of painted
plaster frescoes in
still-vivid hues depicting
scenes of
people, plants, and animals.
That is from the queen's
bathroom.
I would like to have
such a bathroom.
Still farther down, they
encountered rows of huge
gypsum blocks, the walls of a
vast prehistoric building.
Evans had come upon the ruins of
a sophisticated Bronze Age
civilization, previously
unknown, that had flowered on
Crete from about 1850
to 1450 BC.
Predating the Greek classical
age by 1,000 years, it was the
oldest European civilization
ever discovered.
At 48, Arthur Evans was already
one of the foremost
archaeologists in Britain.
His discovery at Knossos, which
the newspapers swiftly
relayed around the world, would
make him among the most
celebrated ever.
For the sprawling building
beneath the knoll, he swiftly
concluded, was none other than
the palace of King Minos, the
legendary ruler of Crete.
It was for Minos, legend held,
that the architect Daedalus
had built the Cretan labyrinth,
which housed at its
center the fearsome Minotaur,
half man, half bull.
As Evans's investigation would
reveal, the palace at Knossos
spanned hundreds of rooms
linked by a network of
twisting passages.
Surely, he would write, this
vast complex was the historic
basis of the enduring myth
of the labyrinth.
Unseen for nearly 3,000 years,
the Knossos palace was hailed
as one of the most spectacular
archaeological
finds of all time.
In his first season alone, Evans
uncovered an exquisite
marble fountain shaped like
the head of a lioness,
carvings of ivory and crystal,
and, still more impressive, a
carved alabaster throne,
the oldest in Europe.
But these treasures paled beside
what Evans found on the
excavation's eighth day.
On March 30, a workman's
spade dislodged
the first clay tablet.
On April 5, a whole cache of
tablets, many in perfect
condition, was found in a single
room of the palace.
The tablets, when Evans
unearthed them, were Europe's
earliest written records.
Inscribed with a stylus when the
clay was still wet, they
dated to about 1450 BC, nearly
seven centuries before the
advent of the Greek alphabet.
The characters they
contained--
outline drawings in the shape
of human figures, swords,
chariots, horses' heads, and
other tiny pictograms--
resembled the symbols
of no known
alphabet, ancient or modern.
Evans named the writing system
Linear Script Class B, Linear
B for short.
He had also turned up evidence
of a somewhat older Cretan
script, which he called, quite
reasonably, Linear A. The end
of his first season's dig, he
had unearthed more than 1,000
tablets written in Linear B.
Though Evans couldn't read the
tablets, he immediately
surmised what they were, the
administrative records
carefully set down by palace
scribes documenting the
day-to-day workings
of the Knossos
Palace and its holdings.
If the tablets could be decoded,
they would open a
wide portal onto the daily life
of a refined, wealthy,
and literate society that had
thrived in Greek lands a full
millennium before the glories
of classical Athens.
Once their written records could
be read, the Knossos
Palace and its people,
languishing for 30 centuries
in the dusk of prehistory, would
suddenly be illuminated.
With a single stroke, an entire
civilization would
become history.
But which civilization was it?
As Evans well knew, many ethnic
groups had passed
through the Bronze Age Aegean,
and there was no way to tell
whose language and whose culture
Linear B represented.
To him, though, this seemed
a small impediment.
Evans was already
something of an
authority on ancient scripts.
And with characteristic
assurance, he assumed he would
one day decipher this one.
But Evans underestimated the
formidable challenge Linear B
would pose.
An unknown script used to write
an unknown language is a
locked room mystery.
Somehow, the decipherer must
finesse his way into a tightly
closed system that offers
few external clues.
If he is very lucky, he will
have the help of a bilingual
inscription, like the Rosetta
Stone, which furnished the key
to deciphering the hieroglyphs
of Ancient Egypt.
Without such an inscription,
his task is all but
impossible.
As Evans could scarcely have
imagined in 1900, Linear B
would become one of the most
tantalizing riddles of the
first half of the 20th century,
a secret code that
defied solution for more
than 50 years.
The quest to decipher the
tablets or even to identify
the language in which they were
written would become the
consuming passion of
investigators around the globe.
Over time, two besides Evans
emerged as best equipped to
crack that code.
One, Michael Ventris, was a
young English architect with a
mournful past, whose fascination
with the tablets
had begun as a boyhood hobby.
The other, Alice Kober, was a
fiery American classicist, the
lone woman among the serious
investigators, whose immense
contribution to the decipherment
has been all but
lost to history.
To Ventris, the solution brought
worldwide acclaim.
But before long, it also
brought doubt, despair,
personal and professional ruin,
and, some observers
believe, untimely death.
All this, of course, was decades
in the future that
March day at Knossos when the
first brittle tablets emerged
from the ground.
But of one thing Arthur Evans
was already certain.
Guided by the smallest of clues,
he had come to Crete in
search of writing from a time
before Europe was known to
have writing.
And there, he now knew beyond
doubt, he had found it."
So now that you've found it,
what do you do with it?
Assuming you are the decipherer,
your first order
of business is to find
out exactly how much
trouble you're in.
Every written document transmits
linguistic signals
to its readers on two levels
simultaneously.
One, the language of the text,
and two, the script
used to write it.
When you confront any
inscription, ancient or
modern, you'll find that one
or the other of these
elements, and sometimes
both, may be unknown.
In combination, our two elements
give us four possible
relationships between the
language of a text and its
script, and some combinations
turn out to be much harder to
decipher than others.
We can plot these relationships
by means of this
handsome little four-cell
table.
So let's start with the simplest
case, represented by
the blank cell on
the upper left.
Here, a known language is
written by means of a known
script, as in--
that's the easy part.
The other three cells represent
decipherments of
varying difficulty.
But the one I want to focus on,
because it describes the
Linear B situation perfectly, is
the cell on the lower right
where an unknown language
is written by means
of an unknown script.
This is the most fiendishly
difficult of our four cases
for it thrusts the decipherer
into a linguistic terra
incognita without so much as
a map or a compass at hand.
And that is precisely the
situation that the
investigators of Linear B found
themselves in for five
decades after Arthur Evans
unearthed those
first tablets in 1900.
The language of the tablets was
unknown, and the script
used to write that language,
well, that was a thicket of
strange, beguiling symbols.
What you're dealing with, then,
is indeed the linguistic
equivalent of a locked
room mystery.
And there is no possible way
to get hold of a key.
Or is there?
Even in our toughest case, where
both language and script
are unknown, the script itself
turns out to be filled with
internal clues.
It's the decipherer's
job to know how and
where to find them.
If you are that decipherer and
you are staring down an
unknown inscription, you need to
begin by subjecting it to a
very particular series
of diagnostic tests.
Each test is a little forensic
exercise designed to coax the
script, bit by bit, to yield
up its identity.
Now, the first test is so
obvious that decipherers
sometimes forget to do it.
You have to establish at the
very beginning whether the
tangle of symbols in front of
you actually is writing.
Suppose in your excavation you
unearth this tablet with its
rows and rows of primitive
symbols.
Is this writing?
In fact, it is a painting by
Paul Klee done in 1927 called
Pastoral (Rhythms).
Now suppose you unearth
another artifact, this
whimsical stone carving.
Could that possibly
be writing, that
silly-looking thing?
And indeed it is, as
someone knows.
These are ancient Mayan
hieroglyphics, a writing
system deciphered only in
the late 20th century.
So once you've established that
you indeed have writing,
your next task is to establish
exactly what kind of writing
system you have.
And to do this, it's helpful to
think of a writing system
as a kind of map.
At bottom, all writing really
does is map the sounds of
spoken language onto a series of
designated graphic symbols,
the characters of the script.
There are only three types of
mapping possible, and every
writing system in the world is
one of these three types or
some combination of them.
In our first type of writing
system, a character stands for
a whole word.
This is a logographic system,
and the best known example of
it is, of course,
Chinese writing.
In the second type, a symbol
stands for a smaller unit, a
syllable, like "ma" or "pa" or
"bo." And here we have the
Cherokee syllabary invented
by Chief Sequoia in 1819.
And this is a classic example
of syllabic writing.
The third type is one that we
English speakers know well in
which characters stand usually
for just one individual sound.
And that, of course,
is an alphabet.
So when you're staring down an
unknown writing system and you
need to figure out what
kind of system it is,
how do you do it?
In principle, you can do it with
a very simple diagnostic.
Just count the number of
different characters the
script contains, and the total
will tell you what kind of
writing system you're
looking at.
If the number is very large,
in the thousands or tens of
thousands, of course you're
looking at a logographic
system, like Chinese, where
each word has its own
designated symbol.
If the number is between about
80 and 200, then you have a
syllabic system, like the
Cherokee script, which has 85
characters.
If the character count is only
in the dozens, however, as in
a writing system that has,
say, 26 symbols, then of
course, you're looking
at an alphabet.
Now, after you've determined
what kind of writing system
you have, your next task is to
figure out the direction in
which the script runs.
We lovers of the Roman alphabet
are accustomed to
scripts running from
left to right.
But we also know that other
scripts, like Hebrew and
Arabic, run from right to left,
and still others, like
Chinese and Japanese, are
written from top to bottom.
But scripts can run
in stranger ways.
In its earliest days, the
Greek alphabet, like its
mother, the Phoenician alphabet,
which was a Semitic
script, was written from
right to left.
Eventually, Greek settled into
its familiar left to right
order, an order that the
alphabets of the world
descended from it share today.
But for a time in between,
Greek writing literally
flopped back and forth within
a single document, running
from left to right and
from right to left
in alternate lines.
The result is a curving thread
of script that calls to mind a
furrowed field, and it's known
as boustrophedon, Greek for
"as the ox turns." And notice,
too, that in the right to left
lines, the ones marked in red,
the direction of each
individual letter is
also reversed.
So how do you determine
the direction of
an unfamiliar script?
The most effective test is to
scan the writing surface for
what we call white space, places
where the text has
filled out a line
incompletely.
If some archaeologist of the
future were to study a page of
an English, and I happen to have
a pretty good one right
here, the unfilled spaces at
the right hand edge of many
paragraphs would tell him
instantly that the Roman
alphabet runs from
left to right.
Your last immediate task
is to find word breaks.
We Roman alphabet users
are spoiled.
We have these lovely,
easy-to-spot things called
spaces between the words
of our written texts.
But not all writing systems
bother with
marking word divisions.
The boustrophedon writing we
saw a moment ago was a
continuous stream of characters
with no word breaks
of any sort.
And without knowing where word
breaks begin and end, you are
at a deep disadvantage.
You have no easy way of telling
whether the system is
logographic, syllabic, or
alphabetic, what the language
of the inscription might be, or
even if the inscription is
writing at all.
So what did all these elegant
diagnostic tests tell Arthur
Evans about Linear B?
To start with the first
essential question, were the
strange Bronze Age
inscriptions, in fact, writing?
Fortunately for Evans,
Linear B passed
this first test handily.
He understood right away that
the tablets were the archival
records of the palace
at Knossos.
They were grouped together
by subject.
Tablets about horses were
stored in one place.
Tablets about chariots, about
grain, about weapons.
Evans knew beyond doubt that the
tablets were documentary
records, meant to be read.
And I should explain that long
before the Linear B script
could be read, the subject
matter of many of the tablets
could actually be gleaned from
the logograms that were
impressed into the soft clay
sealings that held closed the
wooden boxes in which completed
tablets were stored.
It's the Bronze Age version of
labeling a file drawer to
indicate its contents.
And here are a few of my
favorite Linear B logograms.
They took a lot of
baths, evidently.
And last but not least,
my two all-time
favorites, 3,000 years old.
They are so transparent, they
would be at home today on any
restroom door in the world.
So Linear B was unquestionably
a writing system.
And as such, it was what
we call a mixed script.
It was organized around this
basic set of about 85
characters, a number that falls
squarely within the
count for syllabic systems.
And in addition, it contained
the set of logograms like the
ones we just saw.
Next, Arthur Evans had
to determine the
direction of the script.
And this, too, turned
out to be easy.
So remember, to find script
direction, we
look for white space.
And happily, the Linear
B tablets have
white space to burn.
So he knew immediately, written
from left to right.
Evans's last immediate
task was--
and this tablet, by the way,
to back up for a minute,
counts men.
And then there's our
man logogram down
the right-hand edge.
Evans's last task was to
look for word breaks.
And here, too, the
Linear B scribes
did him a great kindness.
On the tablets, the scribes
had thoughtfully incised
little tick marks which
indicated the spacing between
groups of characters.
So you can see how much
information it's actually
possible to wring from an
ancient script without even
knowing what language it records
or what sounds to
ascribe to any of
its characters.
Using just these kind of
diagnostics, Evans did a
masterful job of coaxing all
this information from the
tablets very early on in the
first couple of years of the
20th century.
But after that, he made
almost no progress.
Though he lived another four
decades and worked ferociously
on the script to the end of his
life, he was never able to
determine what language Linear
B recorded, how any of its
characters was pronounced, or
what virtually any of its
words meant.
As a result, Linear B acquired
the well-deserved reputation
as one of the most intractable
puzzles in history.
When Evans died in 1941 at the
age of 90, the meaning of only
a single Linear B
word was known.
The word was this.
And while nobody had any idea
how to pronounce it, context
revealed its meaning.
The word was seen over and
over at the ends of
inventories on the tablets,
just before the tally.
And here it is in two
places on the big
tablet we saw earlier.
And the tallies come after it.
So context reveals it almost
certainly means total.
All in all, total wasn't much
to show for 40 years' work.
Then along came Alice Kober,
the great unsung heroine of
the Linear B decipherment.
It was Kober, sitting night
after night at her dining
table in Brooklyn, who hunted
down and identified the hidden
patterns within the script that
would furnish the key to
its decipherment.
Alice Elizabeth Kober was born
in Manhattan in 1906, the
daughter of recent Hungarian
immigrants.
A brilliant student, she
attended Hunter College here
in Manhattan, and we are
fortunate enough to have her
transcript.
And what I love about Alice is,
look how well she did in
courses that matter, and
look how she did in
courses that don't.
We like Alice.
At Hunter, Kober majored in
Latin and minored in Greek.
And it was there in a class on
early Greek life that she
appears to have encountered
Linear B. She
was immediately hooked.
Undeciphered scripts have
that effect on people.
And on her graduation in 1924,
she announced to anyone who
would listen that she would one
day solve the riddle of
the script.
In the end, after spending
almost 20 years attacking the
problem, Alice Kober almost
kept her word.
Scholars now agree with that
without the painstaking
advances she made, Linear B
would most likely never have
been deciphered when
it was, if ever.
And scholars also agree that
Kober herself might well have
been the one to decipher
it if she had only
lived a little longer.
Kober began her analysis of the
script in the early 1930s.
She spent the next two decades
scouring the inscriptions for
repeated patterns of symbols
that all by themselves would
illuminate the structure of the
language of the tablets.
She kept at it until very nearly
the day she died in
1950, just two years before
Michael Ventris cracked the
code using the methods
she had devised.
But because history is nearly
always written by the victors
and the story of Linear B has
long been a British masculine
triumphal narrative, Kober's
vital contributions to the
decipherment have remained
largely overlooked until now.
Kober earned master's and
doctoral degrees in classics
from Columbia.
And in 1930, she joined the
faculty of the newly created
Brooklyn College.
Throughout her archived
correspondence, a good 1,000
pages, she laments the necessity
of working and the
time it took away from what
she considered the true
enterprise of her life--
the deep, serious business of
deciphering Linear B. She was
saddled with a heavy teaching
load, but night after night,
after her classes were taught
and her papers graded, she sat
at the table in the house in
Flatbush that she shared with
her widowed mother, cigarette
burning at her elbow, and
poured over the strange
Cretan inscriptions.
Alice Kober never married, nor
is there evidence she ever had
a romantic partner.
Her life was her work, and what
a great, great deal of
work there was.
When she began her analysis of
Linear B, Kober kept her
extensive tabulations in
a series of notebooks.
But during World War II and for
years afterwards, paper
was extremely scarce, and she
could no longer get notebooks.
Undaunted, she cut out by hand
an enormous series of ersatz
index cards using the backs of
old greeting cards, church
circulars, examination Blue Book
covers, and it must be
disclosed, an awful lot of
checkout slips she pinched
from the Brooklyn
College library.
On the blank sides of her
homemade index cards, like a
cryptanalyst unraveling a
cypher, Kober notated in her
tiny hand every possible
statistic about every
character of Linear B in every
inscription then known--
a character's frequency at the
beginnings of words, the
middles of words, the ends of
words, its frequency in
combination with every other
character of the script, and a
great deal more.
Over the years, Kober hand-cut
and annotated 180,000 cards,
storing them in the one paper
product of which, sadly, she
appeared to have no shortage.
From the beginning, Kober
approached the decipherment
differently than any other
investigator, and these
differences let her progress
farther than anyone else had.
For one thing, she adamantly
refused to speculate on either
the language of the tablets or
on what sound to ascribe to
any Linear B character.
What she did that
was so radical--
for no decipherer
of any script in
history had done this--
was to treat the symbols of
Linear B as abstract objects
of pure form.
Rather than speculating on what
words the inscriptions
held or on how to pronounce any
of those words, she looked
ceaselessly for patterns
glimmering
within the script itself.
Now, Kober knew that to solve
the riddle of Linear B, a
decipherer would have to inhabit
a world that was, as
she evocatively described
it, a world of
form without meaning.
And of all the serious
investigators, she was most
willing to dwell in that world
for however long it took.
Now, when I was working on the
book and I was writing this
passage about form without
meaning, there came to me
unbidden a haunting riddle
from my childhood that I
hadn't thought of in probably
almost 40 years.
And on a small scale, the riddle
gives a really nice
taste of what it's like to
analyze written characters as
objects of pure form without
any recourse to meaning.
And by pure coincidence, the
solution to the riddle is all
too relevant to Alice
Kober's life.
So here it is.
So what's being described
here?
If we solve the riddle a line
at a time, we get a crossbar
and a circle complete, an
upright where two half-circles
meet, a triangle standing
on its own two feet, two
half-circles, and a
circle complete.
Pure objects of form.
As Kober approached the far
more difficult problem of
Linear B, considering form
independent of meaning let her
spot patterns that others
had missed.
And it was codifying these
patterns that furnished the
greatest step forward
in the decipherment.
And because her methods allowed
the symbols of the
script to be analyzed entirely
in the abstract without regard
for their sound value or for
the language of the script,
they could be applied with equal
precision to any unknown
script used to write an
unknown language.
And it was just these methods
that ultimately let Michael
Ventris decipher Linear B.
But by the late 1940s, Alice
Kober was seriously ill.
As I learned in writing this
book, cause of death is
routinely redacted from New York
City death certificates
of this period, so precisely
what killed her will remain
one of the enduring
small mysteries of
the Linear B story.
But based on her history of
chain smoking, she almost
certainly had some
form of cancer.
But let's look more closely at
two of the vital discoveries
she was able to make
in her short life.
She died at the age
of only 43.
Her first great discovery, made
in the mid-1940s, was
that the language of Linear B,
whatever it was, had been an
inflected language.
That is, that it relied on word
endings, much as Latin or
German or Spanish
does, to impart
grammar to its sentences.
Now, how was she able to know
this without being able to
read the tablets?
The discovery came from her
rigorous search for patterns
in the script.
Among the patterns Kober
identified were the ones that
can be seen in these three
groups of related words.
Now, most of the groups Kober
identified contained three
related words, and columns two
and three here are typical in
that respect.
Michael Ventris would waggishly
name these trios of
related forms "Kober's
triplets." So I'd like you to
pay special attention to the
triplets in column three and,
in particular, to the last word
in the column, which will
turn out to be the lynchpin on
which the decipherment turns.
Now notice that each group
of words shares a
similar set of endings.
Much as in Spanish, the words
"hablo, I speak," "quiero, I
want," and "puedo, I can do,"
where there the O ending
encodes the concept first-person
singular.
In the Linear B examples,
as in the Spanish, the
highlighted portions of the
words are the inflections, and
the un-highlighted portions
are the stems to which the
inflections attach.
Now this pattern of inflection,
in turn, let Kober
identify critical relationships
among the
characters of Linear
B. And this was her
second great discovery.
To take a very simple example,
in column two here of our
triplets, these two characters,
which I'm now
highlighting in pink, link a
word's stem to its suffix.
And they turn out to be related
to each other in
extremely revealing ways.
As Kober discovered, because of
their crucial position in
the word-- she called them
the bridging characters--
these characters will always
start with the same consonant
but end in different vowels,
just as the symbols 'ba" and
"bo" do in English.
The same thing is true of the
corresponding characters in
column three, whatever those
shared consonants and vowels
might actually turn out to be.
Before she died in 1950, Kober
was able to draw up grids of
these related characters.
And as she well knew, if the
sound values of even a couple
of characters could be
determined, then the
interdependencies she had
plotted would let the whole
grid fill itself in in a kind
of domino reaction.
It reminds me today of
a Sudoku puzzle.
This is the abstract grid that
Kober drew up with just five
pairs of characters, including
the two pairs we saw in the
previous slide.
There they are.
And this was the great payoff
that she was able to reap from
having lived for so many
years in this world of
form without meaning.
And it was precisely these
relationships that would let
Michael Ventris, after he read
Kober's published articles in
the late 1940s, make a crucial
intuitive leap and then, using
this web of interdependencies
that she had set up, decipher
Linear B.
Now the extraordinary thing
about Ventris is that he was
neither an archaeologist,
like Arthur Evans, nor a
classicist, like Alice Kober,
nor a scholar in any other
field that might have made
him a likely decipherer.
He was, in fact, an architect.
You can see his magnificent
architect's penmanship on
display in one of the hundreds
of Linear B inscriptions he
copied by hand.
And even more striking to me,
you can see it on display in
his everyday handwriting,
which looks like fine
letterpress printing.
Now, Michael Ventris was almost
certainly the most
natively brilliant of the three
central actors in the
Linear B drama.
He had a prodigy's gift for
inhaling entire foreign
languages and could be speaking
like a native in a
matter of weeks.
He also had an obsession with
the tablets that began in
1936, when he was 14 and saw
them in a London museum on a
class trip.
Before he was out of his
teens, his attempts at
deciphering Linear B would be
a consuming distraction from
great loss.
Both of his parents had died,
one by suicide, by the time he
was 18 years old.
In June of 1952, after spending
more than half his
life in the grip of Linear B,
Michael Ventris, just shy of
his 30th birthday, solved
the riddle.
His decipherment made him world
famous, but in the view
of some observers, it also
cost him his life.
He died just four years later
at 34 in a swift, strange,
inadequately explained accident
that may in fact have
been suicide.
But in his short life, Michael
Ventris managed to solve one
of the greatest riddles
in Western history.
And his solution took flight
from this great intuitive leap
that he made in the
spring of 1952.
The leap involved the sets of
inflected words he had dubbed
Kober's triplets.
Now, let's look again at that
third column of triplets we
saw a moment ago, and in
particular, at the third word
in the column.
Now, you have actually
encountered this word already
in the very first slide
of the day.
Here it is, front and center on
our handsome book jacket.
In the spring of 1952, as he
worked feverishly on the
script in his elegant London
flat, Ventris made a
remarkable conjecture.
Now, everyone knew that the
tablets were the municipal
documents of this Bronze
Age Cretan kingdom.
What if, Ventris wondered, some
of the related words in
Kober's triplets were actually
related forms of Cretan place
names, forms analogous to
English sets like London,
Londoner, or Brooklyn,
Brooklynite, Brooklynese?
It was a truly brilliant
conjecture.
Just think for a minute about
the municipal documents in
your own life.
I live here in Manhattan, and
when I examine all the papers
I've accumulated over the
years, from marriage
certificate to local tax forms
to a billion jury summonses, I
observe they all have
one thing in common.
Somewhere on each of them,
prominently featured, appear
the words "City of New York."
Now, there was every reason to
believe that the tablets,
which were the civil documents
of an ancient Cretan culture,
might contain something
similar.
With this in mind, Ventris began
assigning sound values
experimentally to the characters
in Kober's
triplets, based on the
relationships among the
characters she had previously
mapped out.
One word, in particular, reared
up seductively, and
it's our old friend
from column three.
So let's do what Ventris did
now and examine the word a
syllable at a time.
Ventris's own ongoing analysis
of the script already
suggested to him that the first
character stood for the
syllable "ko." He thought the
next character stood for the
syllable "no." That left only
the third character, which
other evidence suggested
stood for "so."
The result, ko-no-so, suggested
a very particular
place, and not just any place,
but Knossos, the principal
city of Cretan antiquity.
So on the strength of this word,
Ventris plugged sound
values into other words on the
tablets, and they too yielded
important Cretan place names.
And one after another, these
place names let the solution
to the riddle mass
before his eyes.
On June 1, 1952, Ventris took
the microphone at BBC Radio to
announce to the world his
remarkable discovery.
Linear B, it turned out,
recorded a very early dialect
of Greek, spoken long before
Hellenic peoples were known to
have existed, 500 years before
Homer, and a good seven
centuries before the advent
of the Greek alphabet.
What happened was this.
In about 1450 BC, invading
Greeks, who were rude,
unlettered people, poured from
the mainland into Crete.
And the high Cretan
civilization, the Minoan
civilization that they
immediately proceeded to
overrun, had, among its other
attractions, this magical
indigenous method for taking the
sounds of spoken language
and setting them down
permanently on wet clay.
And this indigenous Cretan
script, by the way, which is
several centuries older than
Linear B but looks a great
deal like it, is what we
now call Linear A.
Now, the Greek conquistadors
knew a good thing
when they saw it.
They took this indigenous Cretan
script, adapted it for
use with their own language, and
eventually carried it back
with them to the mainland.
And indeed, tablets written in
Linear B were subsequently
found at several
mainland sites.
So in sum, what we have in the
tablets are the documentary
records of the first Greek
peoples, the Bronze Age heroes
of whom Homer would one day
sing, men and women who lived
in the age of Odysseus and
Helen and Agamemnon.
And it is thanks to three
remarkable 20th-century
heroes, Arthur Evans, Michael
Ventris, and Alice Kober, that
these extraordinary records have
been unearthed, unlocked,
and after 30 centuries, are
readable once more.
Thank you for coming.
I'll be happy to
take questions.
[APPLAUSE]
MARGALIT FOX: Anybody?
AUDIENCE: Where did the--
AUDIENCE: Grab the mic.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
You mentioned that the thing--
he had clues from the text
about ko, no, and so.
Where did those clues
come from?
MARGALIT FOX: Right.
Naturally, for the sake of time,
I had to elide that bit
for the talk.
I can't get anything
by you guys, I see.
So what I'll say, and this is
not self-interest speaking,
it's in the book.
But Ventris had indeed been
toying with the script for
literally half of his 30
years by that point.
I can tell you one thing
very briefly.
We'd already established this
marvelous what I think of as
the Sudoku web of dependencies,
where if you get
one or two sound values,
suddenly the dependencies give
you the others like a chain
reaction in chemistry.
Ventris was actually brilliantly
able to get five
sound values.
And we discuss this
in the book.
The Linear B syllabic writing
system or syllabary, as it's
known, was what's called
a CV type of syllabary.
There are different types.
CV, of course, represents
consonant, vowel, consonant,
vowel, in regular alternation.
So it's ideal for writing a
language whose words are
structured phonetically that
way, like Hawaiian, consonant,
vowel, consonant, vowel.
But if you're a scribe, and this
is the only tool you have
to work with, suddenly you're in
real trouble when you have
a word that starts
with a vowel.
What do you do?
There's no symbol for it.
And Ventris, through doing
years of minute frequency
analysis, much as Kober was
independently doing, made the
inspired discovery that of the
85-some characters in Linear
B, there were five that
came up with seemingly
disproportionate frequency at
the beginnings of words.
And he determined correctly that
these were what he called
pure vowels.
So in those five characters, he
suddenly knew these five,
in whatever order, are "ah,
eh, ee, oh, oo." And from
there, he was able to get this
grid of dependencies to pay
dividends and eventually
getting the
syllables of ko-no-so.
So that's the fast
explanation.
Someone else?
AUDIENCE: What is the current
status of Linear A?
MARGALIT FOX: Undeciphered and
will always remain so for the
most eminently pragmatic,
quotidian reason in the world.
There aren't enough data.
Many fewer tablets were found.
And as anyone who solved a
cryptogram knows, the longer
your ciphertext, the better
statistically your odds of
decipherment.
So unless some Aladdin's cave
bursting with Linear A
inscriptions is one day found,
Linear A will probably always
remain one of the great
undeciphered
scripts of the world.
And there are still a
number out there.
Someone else?
Well, thank you.
Oh, yes.
AUDIENCE: One here.
MARGALIT FOX: Excellent.
AUDIENCE: Maybe just one
on this side, please.
MARGALIT FOX: Do you
want to go ahead?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Now, you mentioned
that the tablets
were municipal records.
Was anything else written
in Linear B?
MARGALIT FOX: Very little.
Linear A is also--
again, they know from the
pictograms, comparable records.
A few Linear A inscriptions,
which they know from the kind
of objects they're inscribed
on, are clearly religious
dedications.
But Linear B, in finding the
Linear B archive, Arthur Evans
had basically unearthed the
record room, the account books
of this kingdom.
And that has caused some
observers over the years to
say, well, they're boring.
There's no literature.
Well, come on, guys.
There wasn't literature 500
years later in Homer's day, so
what did you expect?
But what there is, and the whole
last chapter of the book
talks about this, is it's like
the equivalent of an
anthropologist of the future
coming here and unearthing the
National Archives and would know
immediately how men and
women lived in the 19th
century, 20th century.
Well, here, too, we know from
the tablets what crops were
harvested, what goods were
made, what products were
bought and sold, what was
sacrificed to the gods.
The gods liked to get a lot
of wine, apparently.
They weren't stupid.
And we even see fascinatingly
this pre-Greek society
becoming Hellenized, where you
see the names of familiar
Greek gods, like Poseidon and
Zeus, standing shoulder to
shoulder with these weird,
indigenous pre-Greek gods with
names like Mistress
of Wild Horses and
Mistress of the Labyrinth.
So you learn how these Bronze
Age women and men lived every
day 3,000 years ago from these
very quotidian records.
AUDIENCE: Have the same
techniques been tried against
Etruscan or other
lost languages?
MARGALIT FOX: Say again,
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Have the same
techniques been tried against
Etruscan or any other
lost languages?
MARGALIT FOX: I believe so.
In fact, the interesting thing
about Etruscan, which is a
lost non-Indo-European language
of ancient Italy,
Michael Ventris, from the time
he was a boy until literally
weeks before this Greek solution
asserted itself in
front of his eyes, fervently
believed that the tablets were
written in a form of
ancient Etruscan.
And of course, Kober, who met
him once in 1948, and they
clearly didn't think much of
each other, he was committing
the cardinal sin of imputing--
he was working from the wrong
end of the telescope.
He ascribed a language first and
then, of course, tried to
make the data sets go into all
sorts of configurations they
didn't want to go
into to, voila,
make it come out Etruscan.
And she remained adamantly
agnostic on the language of
the tablets for just
this reason.
To answer your question,
I'm sure the
techniques have been tried.
And of course, now that we are
in the computer age, there are
all kinds of digital techniques
that are available
for archaeological decipherment
that these people
didn't have.
That's the other amazing thing
about Linear B is it was all
accomplished entirely by hand
without the aid of a single
computer or a single bilingual
inscription that, like the
Rosetta Stone, would give Linear
B on one side and a
known language in a known
script on the other.
One has never been found for
Linear B to this day.
AUDIENCE: Did Linear B have a
system of inscribing numbers
using figures as well?
MARGALIT FOX: Yes, they did, and
we, unfortunately, didn't
have time to show it.
I can describe it.
because of course, the tablets
were inventories of, we bought
500 pigs today, and stuff.
And so the tablets, like
anybody's account books, teem
with numbers.
And fortunately for Arthur
Evans, the numerical system
was quite transparent, and he
was able to work that out
right away.
They, as we do, use a base
10 numerical system.
But strikingly, their base 10
system is recorded by means of
just five symbols.
So there's one symbol, for
instance, for the number one.
It's a little vertical line.
And so if you want to write the
number nine, the scribe
would just make nine
of those symbols.
The number 10 is a
horizontal line.
So to write the number 99, he'd
write 10 horizontal lines
followed by 10 vertical lines,
and so on, up to--
there's a symbol that
goes-- the highest
order is tens of thousands.
So the system can record any
number up to 99,999.
And there's a very nice picture
of it in the book.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You've established,
or told us that they
established, that the language
of Linear B is Greek earlier
than what we normally think
of as Ancient Greek.
Is there a way of finding a
history in Linear B as a
script to Greek script?
Is there a connection
between the two?
MARGALIT FOX: No, in fact,
there's a disconnect.
What happened is Linear B, we
now know, records what is
called Mycenaean Greek, the
language of Bronze Age era
Greece and these dependencies
that the Greeks colonized.
Not long after the tablets
were written, the various
Mycenaean palatial centers, both
at Knossos and centers on
the mainland, Pylos, Mycenae
itself, some others, were
destroyed in a cataclysm whose
cause will remain unknown.
It could have been a
lightning strike.
It could have been-- it was a
very earthquake prone region.
All it takes is one earthquake
to knock over an oil lamp, and
you have devastation.
It could have been deliberate
sacking.
But the Mycenaean culture
effectively had died out by
about 1200 BC and earlier
on Crete.
The tablets that we have,
written between 1450 and 1400
BC on Crete, what we have is
only the last year of records
of this palatial center.
By 1200, on the mainland, the
palaces were gone as well, and
with them, writing.
What followed then was a
long Greek dark age.
People continued
to speak Greek.
The art of writing was lost.
Because remember, in Homer's
day, 500 years after the
Cretan tablets were inscribed,
the Homeric epics were written
and transmitted orally.
So they didn't have writing
again until the Greek
alphabet, which was, of course,
derived from the
Phoenicians.
The Greek alphabet came in about
800 BC, give or take.
So there was indeed this dark
age of several hundred years
of no literacy.
It's kind of sad.
AUDIENCE: So the language
evolved, but the writing
disappeared.
MARGALIT FOX: Exactly right.
The language continued
uninterrupted, and you can
actually look.
There are words that we now
know how to sound out in
Mycenaean Greek.
The word for the king
or ruler of the
palatial center was wanax.
We would Romanize it as
W-A-N-A-X. Well, that shows up
500 years later in
Homer as anax.
So you can make these
very similar--
you can map a whole philological
chain of a word's
evolution, but not so with
writing, as you said.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Does the fact that
they're written on clay affect
what the symbols are?
I know the Sri Lankan script is
written on reeds, and that
had an impact on the
shape of the--
MARGALIT FOX: It
certainly does.
And it certainly affects
how the symbols look.
It affected it in ways that
made it difficult for
decipherment.
One, just the friability of
the clay, that a lot of
tablets were damaged.
You'll notice it's much easier
to show drawn transcriptions
or now typeset transcriptions
of the tablets than
photographs of the actual
tablets, because they're
incised in such low relief, they
don't photograph well.
And they're eroded by time
and water and soil
and all that besides.
So that's one thing.
And in fact, it affected the
very name of the script.
Why is it Linear B?
Well, the B we know because it's
the successor to Linear
A, the indigenous
Cretan script.
But why linear?
Arthur Evans named it so because
unlike the other
really well-known script written
in clay, Mesopotamian
cuneiform, which was impressed
with a wedge-shaped tool,
these Cretan scripts were made
with linear strokes.
It's much more the way you or I
would write a letter by hand
in our own alphabet,
so hence, linear.
So indeed, the clay did affect
the very form and hence the
very name of the script.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Where can you see the tablets
or the artifacts from the
civilization right now?
MARGALIT FOX: Well, of course,
the easiest place is online.
Just do a Google search.
You guys know how.
But if you want to see them in
the flesh, as it were, in the
clay, many of the Cretan ones
are at the Heraklion Museum.
Heraklion is basically--
Knossos is a suburb of
Heraklion, put it that way.
They're right close together.
Some are in Athens.
And many, because Arthur Evans
was for years also the keeper
of the Ashmolean Museum in
Oxford, as they call their
head curator, many are
at the Ashmolean.
There are a few-- they may be
copies, but good copies--
at the Metropolitan Museum
here in New York.
So that would be my first
stop, were I you.
AUDIENCE: One more follow-up
question about Linear A. Have
there ever been any sort of
archaeological digs looking
for possible remnants underneath
the ash flow from
the Thera eruption?
MARGALIT FOX: Right.
There was an eruption on Thera,
or as we call it,
Santorini, which devastated
the whole region.
There was a tsunami and an ash
fall, and that, too, may well
have contributed to the demise
of these Mycenaean kingdoms.
As for specific digs to
look for Linear A,
that I do not know.
It's an empirical question.
What I can tell you about Arthur
Evans's dig at Knossos
is he went down far enough to
determine that that palatial
site at Knossos had actually
been inhabited as far back as
the Stone Age.
But he wasn't interested in
artifacts from that region, so
he very quickly honed in on the
Bronze Age as the focus of
his search.
Linear A, so far, there just
doesn't seem to be that much.
But as for dedicated
excavations,
that's a good question.
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
Any last questions?
Well, thank you all so
much for coming.
You've been wonderful.
[APPLAUSE]